hello my name is lucas on a
bracket i am a lawyer linguist at the
court of justice of the european union
we draft legal texts
based on the decisions taken by the
members of the court
we also provide the translation of
requests for a preliminary ruling
from  of the jurisdictions of the
different member countries or their
support
if it comes from our
legal order it is because we
constantly reflect on a multitude of
critical language systems and
areas of law, which makes our
work  both diversified and
enriching it is fascinating to be able to
contribute to the jurisdictional activity
of the court where the fundamental decisions
forming the winch are taken well
we regularly follow
legal language training and
we also share our
legal knowledge with
colleagues
if this challenge challenges you  interested do not hesitate
to participate in this contest is maybe you
will be  soon our new
colleague
if you liked this video a writing
that you liked it share them via your
social networks and register
it's another channel